uhoh
uh uhoh uh I a little
b i this
[Music]
C now let me see
you if you let me get lost if you don't
look at the reaction when I hit with the
phone got FY in the back got cello in
the front listen to the reg boy I got
what you want so fly cuz the club got
like the beating the back of the L take
it back go back to being at the waist
lean to the
front just a little bit P be your Fe a
little B ain't nobody here better than
me purple flag to the left who better
than me I got a allar squad who better
than me man listen to the beat who
better than me I paid to get in so I
ain't going to chill in my week been way
too long
I I
my I this cover
I now let me see
you Das why you had to do it like d
ladies taking it look like they breaking
they head breaking they heading back
back back wa now I'm checking shy with
the m
than a baby in the microwave look at how
she wiing she might get
PA a little harder look at how she W she
a party I hope that security remember
the cuz I to W said I never Dro but I
drop you a dollar told her give me a
number and maybe I call her she said
that she knew me and she know I'm a a
out my I my I P this cover I I going
stand I
now let me see
you now drop it to theow drop drop it to
the
flow
now turn
around turn
around now wiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle
wiggle Play
[Music]
Daylight St
like the lady like dang she
fine it
[Music]
uped it
up make
it do
you make
[Music]
M do
you
make make
money
slapz
for
purple stereo
F and we do it like slow down like slow
down
[Music]
likey this is another J dash
production keeping keeping keeping
keeping keeping keeping
[Music]
keeping
hey friends I hope you dug that uh
awesome bit of flow there uh I got
inspired by that song it was really cool
I dug the beat to it so I hope that you
dig it too uh real quickly I just want
to put a huge thank you out there to
flow toys for sponsoring this video and
making it possible for me to get out and
explore parts of DC and Flo every month
if you want to get a set of those uh Flo
mojoo I was using in this video you can
do so by using the promo code drexfactor
10223 at checkout over at flowtoys.com
again that is drexfactor 10 2023 over
flowtoys.com thanks again to flowtoys
for making this video possible and
speaking of thank yous uh big thanks go
to the Friends of the channel big thanks
too dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys uh juggling calling pirate ha light
toys spinballs and Ultra poy for helping
me make the videos on this channel
Channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non- business friend of
the channel That is Becca ponen thank
you so much for supporting my channel my
work and my
mission um and thank you for watching
this video um it also would be made
possible by my wonderful uh supporters
on patreon in particular I want to give
a shout out to my flow patrons who are
appearing on screen now um if you would
like to check out more of the flow
videos I've done over the years I will
go ahead and include a link to a
playlist of those videos down in the
description and if you'd like to support
the channel uh you can do that at the
link to my patreon that is down in the
description as well anyway have a good
one get out and flow yourself today and
I'll see you with a new video real soon
take care now peace